[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
as the world entered an unprecedented
crisis
magnus carlson and chess 24 acted
quickly
to create the first online chess tour of
his kind working
24 7 we brought together the best
players in the world
for the largest online prize fund ever
broadcast live
in 10 languages the tour innovated and
filled the void
created by the lack of in-person play
reaching more people than
any online chess event ever
there was fun and laughter
okay it's time for russian hackers to
attack
internet
[Music]
yeah and then give up the phone
this is hopeless punish is fast these
days
[Music]
resign okay
okay so we will have a fantastic match
tomorrow i'm sure uh
jan is angry as hell now
but any shows support his written so
let's see
there were instructive learning moments
we have discovered
uh e6 was a very strong move for
neapolis she opens up the diagonal of
the queen and at the same time
shots out the d5 bishop from the defense
black has to play rook
seven to protect the corn and the
seventh rank but now the queen comes
from the f5 queen f2 threatening
rookhouse seven and its
curtains so the position is collapsing
right now here black has to resign
and there was lots of great chairs
oh wow wow it's really an incredible
game like showing how a completely lost
position
can gradually turn into a winning
position if you just trade all the right
pieces it's really this game
is really a master class on on the
trades what you should be trading and
what not
and when i said that trading the queens
and the bishops uh
is good for black i never imagined it
would ever happen because it's just it
was so far away from that
wow and it's a special resignation from
dingley
four unique online events and a grand
final
made up the magnus carlson chess tour
and the world took
notice the magnus carlsen chess tour has
been the most watched online chess event
in history already it has become the
world's most prestigious series of
online tournaments
as the first season approaches its
conclusion we want your help to do
something
even bigger our partner for the tour
final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access
to help under-served communities kiva
does incredible work providing micro
loans to help people around the world
create opportunity for themselves and
their communities
when the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covet 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support
thousands of people around the world
chess24 wants to help make that happen
during the tours final we will be
donating 50
of all proceeds from new premium
memberships to kiva
go premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there
you will be supporting people in times
of need through kiva
and if you are premium already you can
buy sponsored premium memberships for
schools in cities and countries of your
choice
in our shop let's show how chess can
play its part
[Music]
together
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but this is the this is the dream
scenario i think magnus
has a force or he likes to state always
having uh attack without sacrificing
anything and
it seems to me like this is exactly the
position that uh
illustrates that did you consider rook
f7 here
obviously uh that's what i spent my time
looking at
but i just felt that my position was so
good that
there was no reason to to go for it
unless i was sure it was winning
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello and a big welcome to all of you
joining us for the magnus carlson
chester benefiting kiva
final i am delighted to be here with all
of you to hang out with
for all the chess action that's coming
up because today could potentially be
ding lyran's last day in his journey
of the magnus carlson chess store
because take a look at this
magnus after losing the first set
bounced back
with two straight set victories and now
leads their match
uh leaving dingler and playing catch up
to two sets
and essentially that means that
dinglaran is in a win-on-demand
situation today otherwise it's goodbye
for him and magnus carlson makes it
through to the finals and of course our
other semi-final bracket was an absolute
crash through by hikaru nakamura wrapped
it up in three sets
and in dominating style daniel dubois
was put through
a blast furnace and did not survive that
i was expecting that match to be a lot
more daniel than what we saw
but hikaru nakamura what a beast he is
in these
formats in this time control in online
play
just all of it and one thing that we are
guaranteed is that regardless of who
makes it
to the finals whether it's ding or
whether it is
magnus it is going to be an absolutely
epic
and a fitting struggle let's take a look
at the format of the event so we have
got it's a
five set match each set consists of four
rapid games played in
15 minutes plus plus 10 seconds if it's
a tie
we get blitz and if the blitz is a tie
it's a five minute plus three second
blitz and if that's a tie then we go
into the armageddon in the armageddon
magnus carlsen will have
the opportunity to pick colors because
he qualified for the finals through a
tournament win
uh while dingler and qualified
ironically because magnus carlsen won
the legends of chess making ding one of
the highest
cumulative scorers of the entire tour
let's also take a look at what the
players are fighting for
the semi-final losers will go back with
forty thousand dollars
big prize fund there and the runner up
hika nakamura is at least guaranteed
of 80 000 but fighting for a lot more
and the winner of the entire tour
will go back with a hundred and forty
thousand
dollars we had an immense day of chess
today
yesterday extremely exciting i think uh
daniel dubov in a must-win situation
tried to create some chances
but really it was all a hikaru nakamura
show and in the match between magnus
and ding wrapped it up in
three games did not need more than that
and we saw him do that in the second set
as well wrapping up the match in three
games straight with the score of two and
a half half we've seen
one of the biggest qualities of magnus
has been in this entire tour not just
what we saw yesterday really
one of the biggest qualities of magnus
carlsen has been his
flawless endgame technique and he had an
interesting conversation with yas about
that
take a look at what he had to say
what did you learn about the chessable
endgame
that people could get for free
um i learned i learned for once that i
used to be extremely stubborn
and now you became flexible or what no i
i think
uh it was a good thing uh extreme
extreme stubbornness in trying to to to
win games right
um and i think that's
that's what the main takeaway um
that even in very simplified positions
there are so many resources
um but the thing is you have to
concentrate you have to calculate right
once you start relaxing that's when your
your opponent pounces um
either by making uh making a draw they
shouldn't have or
winning a game they should have should
have gone um so
i think there there's um there's a lot
to
[Music]
um to learn there and uh
[Music]
i think uh it's also very useful for
people to remember that endings are
they're very diverse there's a lot of
calculation
um there's uh a lot of
um there's a lot of positional
understanding
um and there's a lot of theoretical
knowledge
you need as well so it's it's it's
really um
it's a diverse skill set you need to to
play endings well
wow i think uh it's it's really
incredible to hear the world champion
talk like that because uh
he is definitely in the current
generation perhaps
the strongest player when it comes to
end games we've seen him
we've seen him convert positions which
to mere mortals like us just look like
there's nothing going on there take his
chances
find resources which are so so difficult
to even imagine that they exist
and a very interesting point made by him
that endings are so rich and complex and
require
calculation concentration because in
chess you slip for one moment
and then your opponent gets away with
that either half point or that full
point
the good news for all of us is we might
not be magnus carlsen but we can
learn from magnus carlsen because there
is a free
lesson on chessable that you can check
out magnus carlsen on
endgames it's a it's a brilliant lesson
where the world champion takes us
through one of his games
from the 2013 world championship match
against vishwanathan
and takes us through all the subtleties
of endgame play
what it requires to truly improve and
understand endings a must watch a must
check out and uh
i cannot recommend it enough and more
good news this is just
a teaser a taste of what's to come it's
got lots of exercises for all of us it's
got
a true look into the world champion's
mind while playing one of the most
difficult aspects of our games of our
game which is the end game
but tomorrow the entire course the
magnus touch on end game releases and i
am very excited about that
but before that definitely have a look
at the free lesson
that's on chesapeal that's live on
chesapeal
right now and
also let's take a look at uh we've been
talking a lot about
the theme of this entire event which has
been impact chess
and how how in this how throughout the
pandemic and in a very difficult time
chess has been this
big impact and this big tool that has
kept our sanity going and provided us
with this
amazing amazing tour really of that
chess 24 and the world champion have put
together
and how it's really impacted our lives
and how now
chess chess24 is extremely proud to
support kiva
and use chess to impact community and
give back to the community
so the bar that you see below me right
now is the bar that tells us
how much money the chess community all
of us have raised
for kibas campaign to raise money for
businesses
for enterprises for entrepreneurs
small businesses in underserved
communities which have been hit
badly by the pandemic uh kiva wants to
raise money for them to help them
survive the pandemic and this bar tells
us how much we have contributed to that
cause
so keep that going a big thank you to
all of you who've made
who who've not only invested in their
own chess education by going premium
or perhaps bought it for their friends
friends and families or
or schools and kids that they know but
also contributed
to the community and it will have
a big impact for all of us to come out
better once this
stupid pandemic is done because i can
tell you i'm done
i'm done with it and i'm looking forward
to all the chess action now
and to get back to over-the-board chess
but for now of course we have
the finals coming up and a big road for
dingler and ahead
he has the monumental task if he wants
to make it to the finals he needs to win
two straight sets against
the world champion and you guys have
been a big part of
the entire event by sharing your impact
share stories with us
and continue doing that continue
connecting with us through twitter and
engaging with us so that we can bring up
these stories and have a conversation
and a chat about them
on our show use the hashtag impact chess
let's take a look at some of the
conversations that caught our eye on
twitter
[Music]
we had sudarshan jairam writing in sweet
revenge for grand master hikaru with a
show of total domination against a young
and talented donald dubof
who had defeated him in the linderazabi
finals two months ago
thank you thank you sadarshan for
writing in and yes
yesterday we were speaking about this
that it was just all hikaru i just think
if there's one player who deserves to be
in the final
uh of course given that magnus has won
three out of four events uh so far
besides magnus i would say it's it's
hikaru nakamura he has shown such
consistency
such domination on this in this format
it
it's also not just been about how fast
he plays but his quality of play his
level of play has been absolutely world
class
so completely agree on that i have to
say that especially you know we saw how
linda's abbey
rapid challenge final went i was
expecting that to not be that easy for
for hikaru
but he's just he was just on beast mode
this entire
entire semi-final and i think the
turning point is something we've spoken
about was definitely that set
one game two which was which was really
daniel's moment to shine and
that perhaps could have changed uh
the bracket as we know it right now but
what's done is on congratulations to
hikaru for making it to the finals
let's move on to our next tweet we also
yes big shout out to william marsh and
uh for this amazing arts that he creates
definitely give him a follow to check
out uh to check out
his stunning art that we have and here
we see the finalists nakamura is it
going to be
magnus carlsen or is it going to be
tingler and thank you so much william
for all the effort you put into it every
morning i wake up and i see this and
it makes me smile it's just it's just
fantastic definitely give william
a follow shout out to william let's move
on to the next one
[Music]
it was by mr dodgy and this
is uh according to mr doji who has been
recently
uh who's been recently playing with the
dark arts as we can see
has leaked some footage of ding's
preparation well
i am speechless on that and i can see
that
uh so far it probably hasn't worked that
well um
but yes uh mr doji i don't i'm
speechless it's uh
it's and there we have another one more
dark arts by mr doji there's
there's voodoo everywhere fair and
balanced he had magnus up first and then
he had dingler in because he's got to
keep it
got to keep it even i have to say that
perhaps this one's worked a little more
dingler is down two sets and then we
heard
more from mr dodgy i think just
completely going into it
and uh you know i have to say mr doji i
don't think this is your calling i don't
think voodoo and all this stuff is your
calling because if you think about it
the only player
who you left out daniel dubois he's not
with us anymore in this
entire chess store so i'm really not
sure if this is what you should be
it's uh let's just say that this is not
what you're meant for i don't think it's
working out
risking my life here and then carney
sarah writing in with i will pay big
money to see this tweet on the show
carnacero i will send you my bank
details please send all that money
across to me
and of course um but i have to say shout
out to mr doji definitely one of the
three top
chess accounts that you need to follow
uh edging out magnus carlson on that
list according to me
just kidding but uh it's not all voodoo
and dark arts in there there's also if
you look carefully you
might find some horses in there on mr
doji's um twitter account
and here we have it but you know what
they say you get what you give out
and thank you guys for all that
entertainment that you provide for us
it's absolutely
um it's really funny and really
it's interesting to see all the stuff
that you come up with michael writing in
with
when i subscribed to taz and canada i
did not expect to watch chess but the
magnus carlsen chester finals have been
absolutely reveting
terrific commentary thank you michael
for writing in
um does in canada for those of you who
might not know
it's not for example it's not available
in india is um
is um something like a netflix but for
sports
so if you're a sports addict and you
enjoy sports a lot you can watch all the
shows
i think there's a lot of focus on fight
sports as well as uh
uh football and chess as well
and uh yes you're absolutely right
michael and i think we've seen this
narrative
throughout the year while all sports
came to a halt and
everything was stopped chess kept it
alive chess
while the world got more and more
solitary and people went more and more
indoors
i think chess was the tool that brought
everyone together from their homes
and uh it's been amazing like that and
that does continue and again a big shout
out to chess 24
and the world champion for putting up
this incredible tour
together in a very difficult time and uh
also a big shout out to them for
supporting at the very end
the very final stage an incredible cause
to help businesses survive a very
difficult time and for to help them come
out of the pandemic uh and we had dwight
replying with with the pac-12
counselling postponing you might be
watching chess all fall
yes we've been talking about this
because uh of course uh the magnus
carlsen chester we're at the final leg
of the journey
after this we just have the finals and a
few more days of this door but the
action on chess 24 does not stop there's
a lot more coming up
and i can guarantee you guys that uh
there is a lot of chance to look forward
to
again just uh you all make it possible
whatever is put together is for all of
us as a community to take it in but if
you enjoy it and you've enjoyed the
broadcast and you support the
tour and you support the chess community
consider going premium because that's
what enables us to do
what we are doing do we have more
on twitter yes we do and edward riding
in with today's
impact chess clash brings tingler in and
the chinese dragon versus thor's hammer
i love it magnus carlsen who will
prevail i expect a big fight today
cannot wait for more exciting chess
i cannot wait for more exciting chess so
this is the perfect time to get in our
chess experts
into the conversation because i can see
on my zoom call that
yes and peter are with us edward you are
totally right today is going to be an
epic battle
because ding has to bring in everything
he's got
to the table today um it's now or never
uh magnus carlsen needs one win to
advance to the finals
dinglarin must win on demand yes
peter welcome thank you tanya as
always a pleasure to be with you hello
everyone
uh thank you so much for joining us i'm
delighted of course to be
here to call the action uh with
colleague and friend peter laco
hi peter yeah hi yasir hi tanya
nice to be here it's the fourth day of
the
semi-finals and we have a very very
important match coming up because the
england has to fight for
his life i could not have put that
better than
fighting for his life um uh peter
yes uh what do you what do you
predict in today's as far as openings
and style of play is concerned do you
think that ding
is going to stick to his classical
strategic positional
uh way of playing or are we going to see
an all-out version of ding
going for the naidocs and the more
combative play i think the latter
uh tanya because uh it seemed to me that
coming into the match
ding moved away from his
usual repertoire of knight f3d4 he
is a great great catalan player and
instead he's adopted a very combative
approach as you said with one e4
uh the fact that he trails in the match
makes me question whether his
strategy was right but guess what he won
day one
uh he knows he's got the game to beat
magnus he just needs to take advantage
of his
opportunities and peter that game that
that set yesterday that where he played
a3 and magnus turned the tables
with bishop takes a3 that was
uh a harsh blow
yeah absolutely i mean i
i fully agree with you that we have seen
that uh dingli ram was
somehow experimenting too much uh with
his openings
maybe it was also encouraged by the fact
that he won the very first game of their
match
with e4 and he won it with an ease and
looking back it might feel like
magnus just lured him into this
territory that please you are welcome
play e4
play all these night offs and then uh
dingling even went on to play with white
and with black the night off and we had
seen some incredible clashes yesterday
and what strike me was that
whenever finally this time trouble phase
was coming then somehow magnus was
feeling uh
better himself in this double h position
because
he had simply more experience and and in
this regard yes
one can argue that ding needs to to to
create a mess in order to
to cause magnus trouble but on the other
hand if he's not feeling comfortable
with the mess with
little time on the clock then maybe some
classical positions where he can build
confidence move by move his eventually
devised strategy
but in this respect i think first game
is already very very important because
magnus has the white pieces
and ding has to make sure that he
survived this game if he wants to
have a chance winning today's match
yes indeed peter i think first game is
definitely going to set up the tone
for today you know i don't know how you
feel about this yes and peter but it was
coming to my mind because i was thinking
about this match that
the one match that ding did win in the
first set
of their matchup there were some
technical issues that had played a role
in that
and we had magnus come in and speak
about it as well that how that threw him
off a little bit and i just
i just feel that if all of that does not
happen
it becomes it's extremely hard for for
ding because the last two matches that
we've seen have been all magnus calls
and wrapping it up in three games it's
not even gone to the fourth game
now we know that in over-the-board chess
and with their match-ups in the past
these two have an epic rivalry and
magnus never has it easy
he just never does and ding has in fact
come on top several times in their
matchups
but i have to say that in this online
format and online chess
has proven throughout this store to be a
completely different animal from
over-the-board chess
i have to say that not just the
scoreboard wise but magnus carlsen
is a big favorite in his match against
dingler and
which is a very different story when
they play over the board
yes it has been and again i think
at the start of the show tanya you are
explaining how
um the format really favors a player
like hikaru who literally grew up
online and he played blitz endlessly
thousands and tens of thousands of hours
it feels like online blitz
and the format um
has in some ways kind of favored magnus
too magnus is a phenomenally good
blitz player and rapid player so these
formats
you know i hate to say but they really
do favor two
players specifically our world champion
magnus carlson and hikaru now having
said that
ding at the number three player in the
world in classical chess
defeated uh magnus in
a playoff so again he's got the game
to win and what you said was so true
tanya i can't help but remind everybody
that during a technical uh glitch
magnus returned the point he played
queen g5 takes d2
lost the game because he refused to go
ahead
due to a technical fault and sorry peter
you couldn't get in a word edgewise
there but the game's underway we do have
liftoff and i'm going to leave the floor
to yas and peter to take us through the
action but a quick reminder to our
viewers that you can
um that we are keeping an eye out on the
chess 24
chat and you can connect with us on
twitter using the hashtag impact
chess show your impact chess stories
with us but for now enjoy the game
thank you tanya and we do have liftoff
peter
yeah and i'm pretty sure that we gonna
enjoy this game big time because
we are seeing an opening confrontation
between the two players which i have
been
really looking forward to see in their
match and so far we
haven't had a chance during this finals
because this is exactly the line with
which
uh magnus carson delivered a terrible
blow in the legends uh
tournament against dingli ran and i was
wondering when
ding will get back to his main opening
and let's see what he what he preferred
absolutely well this is probably one of
the most
i want to say difficult theoretical
territories for
any chess grand master this uh bobbinic
bond sacrifice which is now like the
moscow
variation and ding has just challenged
magnus directly with the move
b4 and the knight was pushed away knight
went to a4
and after knight left the scene
knight takes e4 grabbing the center
pawns and i gotta tell you
uh that's about as direct a challenge as
black could could make peter
yeah on the other hand i'm really
curious to see
how deep uh dinglan has prepared all
this variation because
it does not have a good reputation and
basically if you
play b5b for yourself it it must
indicate that
you are coming with a surprise and you
have you must have checked this position
very deeply otherwise you will end up in
trouble
and and in this respect i'm also very
curious to see
how deep magnus's preparation will go
because
this this line is simply supposed to be
nice for white
with lovely compensation and
once you know that it's a lovely
compensation you think like okay my
opponent anyway we'll never play this
line
and secondly if they play then i will
handle it over the board
okay and uh well now you set the table
so
so very well where is the lovely
compensation
yeah the compensation is basically based
on the fact that
uh black has no safe shelter for his
king i mean look at this pawn on g5
uh it basically already guarantees that
whenever black castle short uh his king
will also not feel
very safe uh black right at this moment
is
two pawns up but uh okay the pawn on c4
is gonna fall
any any minute uh so in this regard
one can only think about one pawn and
also
a damaged pawn structure from black so
white has all the
all the reasons in the world to to claim
very nice compensation and knight c5
cc had been blitzed out by dingley run
exactly uh as you mentioned there was a
two pawn advantage
uh magnus could have played bishop takes
c for
reducing his deficit by one pawn right
away
uh he chose the move knight c5 first
because
i was thinking that exactly peter that
knight b
8 to d7 and hacked that bishop
on e5 off the board and therefore i
understand completely magnus has moved
knight c5 he didn't
he wants to maintain his bishop on that
beautiful
e5 square
exactly i mean knight c5 is a very
classy move
but it's also the move i believe you
anticipate as black and
yeah ding has bleeds down c3 i wonder
i wonder where this will lead because if
i would be sure that this is not
preparation
the players just got here by accident
maybe
somebody threw a dice and they had to
start from this
moment i would say that white player is
a clear favorite but
i mean knowing that this was
entered voluntarily by ding changes my
perspective to the position
right and uh again these
two very greatest chess players in the
world
uh you got to assume
that ding's uh ding laren's uh
preparation
is going to be really really on point
today in other words
he's playing a side variation which as
you just said peter yourself
a lot of players don't want to play as
black
therefore he could be surprising magnus
and hopefully his preparation is really
up to it because he again he's two pawns
up and magnus has to prove
the position is full compensation how do
you see it
currently after the move c3 i mean to
say
yeah i i actually don't know exactly
what to see i think we have to
wait for the next couple of moves to to
clarify the situation because
without knowing what engine thinks about
this position
it's it's very difficult because we can
generally explain why white has such a
lovely
position on the other hand let's not
forget yeah the opponent sees the
might fall but it will still take quite
some time to to collect this pawn
and meanwhile of course i believe black
wants to go bishop g7
try to play knight bd7 exchanges
powerful knight on c5
and then if he has a chance to to
relatively safely castle
uh why i say relatively safely because i
believe that once
white castles himself then all these
ideas with h2h4
will not be so dangerous anymore on the
other hand also the white king on e1
does not feel so safe so
i'm expecting magnus sooner or later to
castle
and once black gets all these moves in
and gets rid of the knight on c5
even if he had lost the pawn on c3 in
the meanwhile
then still he's he's pawn up which is
not the main point but
uh also how is white really going to
generate
the very strong very dangerous
initiative exactly
i was in uh bonn germany
2008. i think that was right
for the uh this one upon the
non-vladimir kramnik world championship
match and crazily
enough that world championship match was
decided
in this variation as vichy won with the
black pieces
and you were you were mentioning how
after h6 g5
uh by advancing his pancho black's king
on the king
side isn't going to feel too safe and i
remember in that match that
somehow vichy's king when it got over to
the king side it was very hard for
vladimir
just to go over there and sack it so um
yeah it's it it's one of those
variations in chess
that you just need to prepare really
deeply and i'm very curious
to see how deep the players have
prepared because again
i'm expecting that magnus has been
surprised
whereas ding has prepared uh
for this position where we're we're
about to find out we did see knight d7
by the way peter
yeah we have seen quite a lot of things
so finally
magnus followed as we discussed with
short castle
knight b7 was played before playing
bishop g7 because
most probably it was very very important
to to eliminate this knight as quickly
as possible
the knight takes d7 bishop takes d7
these knights were exchanged magnus
followed it up
with queen beasley and look at this i
mean what the speed
queen beastly bishop g7 bleeds out and
now so queen hd played
but the english has five minutes five
and a half minutes time advantage
exactly and that i don't find to be
surprising because again
it's this uh you know side variations
and how
how deep can you prepare when i think
about the specimen coffer
for example it's such a complex
variation
with so many many many many branches
and if i can prepare deeply one specific
uh i want to say large branch whereas my
opponent has to
you know prepare everything
i feel like i have some advantage now
this move queen a3 makes it very clear
the compensation is simply
black's king ain't going anywhere uh
certainly not
to the king side that's the intention of
queen a3
how do you exactly that was that was the
question they wanted to ask
queen e7 bishop d6 and i go backwards
with the queen
right yeah but
this already indicates that probably you
would never really play queen e7 you
just
asked the question in in order to
uh order to clarify it for the public
yeah because if white gets a
tempo like bishop d6 in and then the
white knight might join the party
to e5 right this is feeling too
dangerous
exactly but the question is how to deal
with it
uh keeping the king in the center is
is not ideal the main problem that the
bishop on g7 is hanging
black cannot really move his knight
because it's pinned
and in this respect maybe then black has
to
insist on playing bishop f8 and maybe
just give the phone and go back
and set him with short castle that's
maybe one
idea or something like c6 c5 sacrificing
the pawn
in order to disbalance white it's
another option
and that's the move as got my attention
exactly peter c
six c five and you mentioned it's a
little bit awkward sometimes white has
to spend some time
just scooping up the pawn on c3 so i'm
thinking if you
play queen take c5 insisting
no you can't castle that after rook c8
at least the spawn on c3 could could
present
um counter play for
black yeah absolutely i mean
suddenly your rook is alive the the
white queen will not find it so easy to
to have a nice queen i mean earlier the
screen a3 was was brilliant but
also it feels like getting rid of the c6
pawn was a big relief for black because
suddenly his bishop
can also join the join the play with
bishop c6
i think the the real question after c5
is that
what happens if white simply just takes
d takes c5 because let's not forget that
black is not up too much materially and
let's just imagine that newcastle and
widely collect on cc
they already material equal territory
and
white has all the older drums with with
his uh
better pieces and still the the somewhat
weakened the
king's king-size structure from black
okay so continue that variation if you
will peter
d takes he fights castles short i mean i
would think that
i'd be very relieved let's say to get
the king out of the center now
queen takes e3 i do have the the tempo
knight d5 which may help me
uh let's say ease some some of the uh
annoying pressure that white certainly
has queen d4 yeah
and if just picking a move for example
i don't know f6 let's just say
uh since then then i think i get control
with bishop d6 you know what i was
wondering
that so you have some crazy ideas like
knight f4
tricky tricky yeah using the fact that
we're always blaming black's
weakened king side pawn structure but
now exactly thanks to this pawn on g5
we have this nice intermediate move
which might bring new dynamics to the
situation
yeah making a virtue out of uh this
advanced g5 pawn at least i do feel
that c5 is a move you definitely want to
consider
but he didn't play queen e7 i was like
no don't do it
but the other thing i wanted to ask is
this pawn on c3
it's kind of funny because it's awkward
for the knight the knight on
on f3 really wants to jump to e5 but
that square is already occupied
uh if black plays some crazy move like
g4
the knight is gonna have to go to a bad
square right peter
that's uh that's a very good point and
maybe this is exactly why
dingley ran hasn't made up his mind yet
because yeah this
g5 g4 is is quite quite a nice toss
the big question is on the other hand
where does this lead because
white has a move like knight e1 and the
knight is heading towards
c5 via d3 and probably g4 you have to
connect anyway with the idea c6 c5
because you have to
make this structure yeah right so now
comes c5
and maybe the there's some differences
key differences i think with the other
variation doesn't need to win just
trades the business
yeah i mean just absolutely picture
perfect
isn't it's no longer on f3
yeah it's it's a very interesting point
because often in all these
anti-moscow variations uh the number of
pawns is not the decisive factor the
factories
whose species will finally be more
active in the right moment
right and in this sense yeah this g4
knight e1 c5 is a very interesting idea
yes it seems to be combining uh two
things now again
as far as i am concerned peter uh
after surprising his opponent with b4
knight a4 knight takes e4
bishop e5 knight f6 we're really
in ding's preparation i'm sure
uh dingler and considered knight c5
and again i've got to figure out before
g4 and before c5 all of this was
on ding's let's say uh study
uh in his study and he's taking so long
so i'm finding it a little bit confusing
your take
on what he could be considering yeah i
think that simply is uh
his preparation has stopped the point is
that uh
when you are coming up with such a
surprise like b4 and now finally g5 g4
have been played so your movie yasar is
is on the board uh what i wanted to
to mention that we don't know whether uh
dingli ran
was happy to play this variation with b5
before or it came out of desperation
yeah because
this is another scenario like he
might have wanted to improve the play
that he played against magnus in the
legends but
finally in the last moment he felt like
no no it's too dangerous i'm not happy
and i'm not ready there
and magnus probably has expects that and
he knows it
better and in this sense out of
desperation he chose an emergency exit
with the line b5 before
and that's why he's not that deeply
prepared or there is another scenario
that simply
after playing this line b5 b4 white has
so many different alternatives
and when you are looking and analyzing
with the computer
computer brings so many new ideas to the
to the position that
often the most simple or most human ways
you can easily miss
in your preparation because you are
simply overloaded with all the
engine suggestions
intriguing because that was actually one
of the areas i really was hoping to
uh probe with you uh peter
because i'm sure so many
people watching our broadcast
have that exact question how to
best use the computer so that you know
it doesn't overwhelm you right like i
mean you want to prepare using the
computer
but you want to understand the ideas
behind the moves and you want to
direct the computer in a certain way so
sometimes if you just leave the computer
on you can get lost in some kind of
maze so uh at some point i'm going to
ask you
like how do you use your computer and
how do you recommend
for amateurs now in the meanwhile we
have seen the move g4 peter
uh and you basically said knight e1 and
stop you didn't consider knight h4
uh why yes somehow
simply this move knight e1 is so natural
because i want to get to
get to c5 and i feel like the knight on
h4
is not not doing that much since i have
no empty points
okay if there would be a nice way to
sacrifice the knight on f5 somewhere and
make use of the e5 but it looks uh um
basically illusionary uh not real so
knight e1 is the natural move and the
english
had followed it up with c5 right
so everything in the spirit magnus took
it with
dtx c5 and black has
castled and again a major relief
for black i always say in the opening
you have only
three goals uh you want your fair share
of the center you want effective
development squares for your pieces and
you want to save king
now in reviewing
who has succeeded in those goals best
peter how would you summarize the
outcome of the
opening thus far well actually
the position is so complex that i'm not
sure if i can evaluate it i can
better explain what what are the trumps
and magnus has played
bishop takes c3 so basically he wants to
make sure that
the knight will never jump with the
tempo but
the point is that one of the big
extras let's say like this yeah big
achievement for black
with g5 g4 as you mentioned that the
knight was kicked away from f3
and the white knight is not able to land
on e5
and this gives black the chance of
placing his bishop on the lovely square
c6
yeah and with bishop c6 i feel like
okay if it's black to move black would
just play queen d5 and would
have a fantastic position so clearly
bishop c6 will be mad by the very
unpleasant luke d1
when you have to leave the d file and
probably that's the reason why
ding hasn't played bishop c6 yet looking
for any alternatives
but everything is based on tempo tempo
because if black is in time to get
active then he will be perfectly fine
but if
white will have time to bring his knight
from e1 to let's say
a dc to e5 or to to some other square
then
long terms black's kingside pawn
structure
cambium can be an issue exactly and just
as you're describing it
one of the things that in the position
really kind of sits out like a sore
thumb for me
is this pawn on g4 you know the old
adage pawns don't move backwards you
know you almost feel like
i'd like to play g4 g5 uh
you know in his his really magnificent
book uh
zurich 1953
david bronstein explained that a pawn on
g4 is like
a sewing needle that pulls
a thread behind it and that in this case
you know black almost feels a kind of an
obligation to play h6
h5 you know further uh
you know pulling his pawn structure
forward because i think in some ways
black as you were mentioning wants to
play bishop c6 and
jump with the knight and i don't know
queen f6 and
get his pieces going and he needs to do
that rather quickly because as you're
pointing out
rook d193 95 uh
you know i can see those moves and i i
want to
see how black counters them
you know i feel like you are a magician
yes sir you know because
you mentioned this move h6h5 and i
thought
wow yes it's very nice of course you
have to tell the
explain the public yeah that after g4 h6
h5 is natural but to my mind i was even
thinking by listening to you that
this will never happen you know
exactly at that moment like couple of
seconds later
ding himself went h5 okay now now i also
got the point that yeah of course black
wants to go knight d5 because this rook
d1 move was so irritating
and already this moves had been played
magnus blitzed out luke d1 and
dink has instantly replied it with
knight d5 that's why he had to
put an extra guard on the g4 pawn bishop
takes g7
king takes g7 also on the board
interesting development exactly and uh
again now you can unders
understand me why i'm always
complaining to the engineers at chess24
that
the players can't hear the
they commentators hear the competitors
and they keep reassuring me that's the
case
yes uh big developments and uh
uh okay now it's not now it's a
free-for-all uh
fight for squares uh the knight on d5
i'm sure
you know dingler and just wants to play
queen g5 sooner queen g5 queen f6 and
bring his rooks and bishop to c6
white quickly just wants to go like i
don't know knight d3 to e5
maybe on a good day uh even f2f3
comes to mind peter what what what's
your take
yeah there are many many ideas uh
one of the most dangerous things in
rapid chess yeah because
if it would be there would just be a
clear-cut way it would be so nice
because you would be able to blitz them
out
but yeah here there is there are really
lot of things to
to calculate to to think about because
on one hand as you mentioned white wants
to go knight dc knight e5 but if after
knight d3 black for example
with queen f6 or with queen g5 nicely
neutralizes this knight
jump then it might be premature to
lose a tempo on knight this remove and
this position
feels like it's very much movement move
i mean the tempo plays a very important
role
and in this regard it's not very nice
that it's white to move
he might be able to call the shots but
if he misses the direction then
black might take over exactly by the way
in
terms of time let me just double check
it does feel like ding
has won the
sweepstakes on the clock now if you've
mentioned uh
in the in their matchups that
when magnus is significantly behind i
mean
two minutes he's down to two minutes
ding has got four
or more minutes uh magnus plays so well
he seems to
catch up on the time in and in fact the
clock hasn't been a major factor
normally for me uh peter i'm one of
those guys i
i like i feel more i feel happier when
i'm ahead on the clock in other words
when i have more time
uh than my opponent but in this match it
hasn't been
a key feature of the match
yeah but i also experienced myself that
having more time on the clock is of
course very very important in this
in general already in rapid play anyway
but
in online chess i feel that it's it's
even more important because
uh i have the feeling that while you
have time
uh it's it's kind of almost no
difference if you are playing uh
online chess or you are playing over the
board chess but when suddenly the clock
thing's done
unless you have some incredible
experience like hicario magnus
for example personally i felt quite
difficult to to to control the
happenings over the board and whenever i
would make a move suddenly i was
i would be like shocked that how on
earth did this cross my mind at
all yeah if it would be over the board i
would definitely not make this move
uh somehow you are distracted but we
have seen from magnus
and also all these other top players
that they are already
very much into this online and i think
that's one of the reasons why
we hardly see big mistakes or we see
very very high quality even with very
little time and that's why we have the
impression that
actually time is never really impacting
the players
but if i uh can say something i felt
like the
reason why fabiano became
so much better now in this online rapid
format and blitz format was that he was
managing his clock
so much better than than earlier and if
we look back at
the tournament that you had been
broadcasting from san luis the the
clutch
then i remember that fabi was all of a
sudden almost having like
eight minutes on the clock in a position
where
like half a year before i think he would
have had clearly
less than five minutes exactly he
definitely sped up his play now
i'm seeing some incredible accuracy i
believe by magnus i really like
his move bishop c4 peter and following
it up
especially with knight c2 and not knight
d3
is now the knight that bishop on c6 that
you were
mentioning you know is on this lovely
diagonal
i mean it's become a target and as
you're putting out white is ready to
play either knight d4
or knight before and i can almost
imagine
a major piece end game scenario coming
up
uh where you know something like rook c8
you take the bishop and you take the
knight on d5 and you before you know it
you're in a major piece end game uh
coming up
but uh ding recognizing that major piece
end game is not favorable for him
he has played knight e seven uh peter
yeah he's trying to get the harmony but
uh
it seems like yeah magnus has played the
move f to f3 so
magnus combined all the ideas in the
position and
we see how nicely he had brought all his
pieces
to ideal squares putting pressure
and i do believe that black was missing
somehow this
extra half tempe because it was not just
one tempo it was
less than that it was a half tempo that
he was missing and
and white sees the initiative so it will
be
very difficult for black to keep
everything together now
wow and you know again i just
yeah i'm a fan boy but this
is really nice i mean it seems like
magnus always somehow he manages to use
he manages to use his
trunks and he plays his cards just
perfectly this move f2 f3
uh what a break i mean the timing
couldn't be more
uh on point as now that black's queen is
on
f6 it's it's pacing a tempo against the
rook on f1
suddenly it feels like black's
position's falling apart
yeah it's it's very dangerous and ding
has played the positional
sacrifice okay positional tactical uh
i don't know how to call it but
basically he felt like the tempo is more
important than the pawn and he has to
keep this
uh false uh closed on the king side
and after gc ate g3 he plays luke fd8 he
wants to hit the knight on d4
and uh it seems like if white would
prematurely take on c6
we have been talking about this powerful
bishop but all of a sudden
this structure maybe this blockading
knight and all the dark spears
including the d4 square which the the
black knight can occupy
would give black quite good compensation
i mean at least definitely practical
chances to create counter play so in
this
sense i feel like something like queen
e3 is
is so much more natural from right side
not to exchange this powerful knight
yeah i couldn't agree with you more
queen e3 the queen on a3
did a very very good job when it landed
there
the queen ma3 was uh
on the diagonal a3 to f8 limiting
black's king from castling now
centralizing the queen with a move like
queen e3 uh and bringing
you know it's strange when we started
this whole discussion
black was two pawns up
over the course of the last 15 moves
it's like he's given back
three pawns that's quite
unusual that you go from a gambit
position
two pawns up to one pawn down
rather a big a a big surprise for me
by the way he he took on c6
i thought that was premature i liked
your logic that you were
saying there peter but he did it and he
said look i'm upon up so
what's the problem and maybe magnus is
right peter
yeah probably i mean i'm still a little
bit surprised that
why you do this but knowing magnus he
probably has his his own ideas
the point is that uh aha and knight d4
have been
answered by g4 from magnus so maybe he's
following a very very concrete
approach he said that yes but if black
is not able to make
good use of this d4 square as that's
what i was also afraid of that
this knight on d4 is is disturbing but
this
gc g4 with the threat of g4 g5 kicking
away the queen on f6 which protects the
knight on d4
that on the knight on d4 will feel
very loose and uh maybe this is just
some very nice judgment by my magnus
yeah it looks like a great tactical
opportunity there this move g4 not the
first move that comes to your mind just
like
you're you're really very happy holding
your extra c5
on and you're thinking to yourself your
king is
nicely protected pawns on g2 g3
f3 uh and then you know you just have to
change that mentality from like
your your king is secure enough you know
play for the win go for the attack
g4 g5 and he did it and whoa
this is surprise peter uh dengleren
ignored the threat of g5
yeah he ignored because first of all he
couldn't do anything against it secondly
he spotted some very nice tactical
counter resource
so basically i'm expecting probably if
i'm not branding anything the whole idea
is based on something like queen f5
look takes d4 queen takes c5 pin
and it's yeah and queen f5 played it's
not so easy to
to get out of this and if you play rook
fd1
i might have the move e5 e5 and
pins galore suddenly um there's a pin on
the d
file that's pinning against the queen
and that looks
yeah and we have rook takes d4 queen
takes c5
on the board can he play bishop takes e6
peter
interface probably
i i have to see what i'm blundering as
well
like it suddenly became like super sharp
uh a moment it looked like some nice
positional considerations after queen e3
but now it's
it's blown up and uh i'm just trying to
at the end of the day
uh keep some material advantage yeah
bishop takes e6
very nice i have to take it back i guess
right and now you can unpin yourself
with rookie four
and probably i have nothing else i have
to go for some
rook and game and hope for my activity
with rook d2
nice exactly rook d2 just in time
to double the rooks on the uh second
rank
yes you cannot stop it with luke f2 and
you cannot really take on e6 yeah bishop
takes e6 had been played
look e6 runs into look cc2 so probably
you have to make a move like king h2
and this is something that bothers me a
bit
rook c c 2 can be answered then by rook
g1
right great activity for black but still
a material advantage for white
exactly and the pawn structure is
very nice for white in long term so and
it's reverses too
or any lucan game even where you collect
the a2 pawn but
i get active in the in the meanwhile
can be very very dangerous for black
in your judgment with this ending
because they appear to be going in this
direction by the way
peter would this ending be winning for
magnus and let me again
boldly state the obvious magnus carlsen
is on the verge of
getting to the finals he needs to win
today's set
or even tomorrow says whereas dingler
and he's
he's do or die he has to win uh the set
of games today they'll be playing
four rapid games or rather the first
player to two and a half
and as you said at the start of today's
game
uh day game one playing with the black
pieces
was so crucial peter yeah i mean i
sensed the simply the point was that
ding wants to play his chess but magnus
is not
giving him the opportunity to play his
chess and
and and then i felt like all these big
experimenting issues
uh were also combined with the fact that
uh
ding was not sure if he plays his lines
he did not get into trouble and then he
felt like
maybe coming up with surprises right
from the beginning might
be a better practical chance or better
practical idea against magnus i mean
this is a very nice illustration from
from magnus yeah that how he deals with
with any surprise
if this surprise comes against something
he believes in yeah because
he believes in the anti-moscow variation
from the right side that yes
i'm sacrificing a poem for initiative
and
i'm ready in the main lines and if you
are going to some sidelines please
do so let me see if you're going to
enjoy yourself or not
exactly and speaking of enjoying himself
magnus carlson has
against the move rook c6 got himself
into a rook
and fought and gained peter worries
material ahead
pawns ahead and uh as we know that's not
a nice way of spending your afternoon
trying to hold an inferior ending
against
this world champion uh magnus carlsen
yeah absolutely i mean i also realized
meanwhile that yeah we had been
talking and we were carried away with
all these lines but after fe 6
white could also not play rook fd1
because
e5 doesn't work anymore thanks to the
open
7 rank with luke d7 and if you have to
take luke d4
then i gonna end up in some end game
anyway which is
clearly better and much easier than what
i was showing where black was getting
contra chances in the double rook end
game very important
point so that was why we saw rook c6
instead and wouldn't you know it
they're in a rook and pawn end game
which just absolutely
dovetails with what is happening today
in our show as it's free
end game lessons time everybody
go to a chessable.com sign
up and get a free endgame course a 20
minute
lesson by magnus carlson
and you can get a taste of
a endgame course that is going to be
released tomorrow
so the price is right a free endgame
lesson
on the end game by magnus carlson and
i have to tell you you mentioned it a
moment ago this three versus two or if
you want to call it three versus one
this looks tragically bad for
black i just don't think that
there's any chances of holding this end
game peter
yeah fully agreed i mean look at games
are famous for their
big margin of drawing chances however
usually those
chances are based on very healthy
structures
from the from the weaker side but being
pawned on and having the horse pawn
structure
and magnus immediately activating his
king with king h2
probably he will make sure that whenever
black plays king g6 he's simply gonna
protect it with rookie five
and if he gets then king g6 h4 and some
f4 g3 set up then
then it's just a question of time when
he will
win this position exactly rather plays
itself
the only thing i can imagine from a
defensive perspective
is peter rook a6 hoping
hoping that maybe one day i can trade
the e6 pawn for the a2 pawn so
um i'm imagining f4 for example rook
takes
well i don't know f4 do i
yeah i'm thinking i'm i'm torn between
king f7 and rook takes a2
but let me just first say rook takes a2
peter
uh i guess these two connected past
pawns are just
terrifying right yeah i think this is
just
hopelessly lost without any practical
chance so you have to go king f7
right as you mentioned of course you
want to
protect your e6 pawn because it's not
just about the pawn but thanks to this
pawn
the white look is less active and a
little bit cut out of the game
okay and how i will deal with this a2
pawn because i don't want to return to
e2
okay i can but it gives you the chance
of
activating your look with luke 3 cutting
off my king of course i can play gc and
then king h the king h4 are still there
and it looks
very very promising but still you feel
like maybe you can be even more precise
and magnus has started with the move f4
not rook a5 but rookie fight pardon me
but a4
good morning everyone
f4 okay uh i was reluctant to make that
suggestion for the obvious reason peter
i didn't want to see king f5 was f4 good
move
well i think if magnus has done it then
it should be a good move but
rookie 5 looked much more natural on the
other hand if magnus knows already that
king f5 is not an issue then
he might think that he anyway needs the
move f4 so yeah let's
check what could happen after king f5
so i like the way you were describing
that so if
magnus makes the move then it's probably
good if your
student makes the move then you are
going to explain to them
they should play rookie by first very
nice
so it depends on who's playing the move
okay got it
okay king of five what's going to happen
here yeah king f5 played of course it's
the only chance
and another big question is also
white has ideas like activating the king
like king g3 and saying that
okay give me this check it looks like
you achieve something what
in fact after king h4 king takes f4 king
takes h5
the g-po might just march and you will
not be able to stop it and king g3 on
the board
ah that's i like that variation i also
like
taking on e6 in that line too uh
rook d three check king h4 king f4
rook e6 that looks like a really great
munch
because you're keeping all the pluses
that white has it
in the position and you've got rook f6
check and chasing the king away and
suddenly
it's all good and we've seen h4 check
king takes f4 okay ding is fighting for
his life and he's trying to get a past
ippon
uh peter yeah but okay now just to check
on the
f5 with luke f1 check and i believe it's
kind of
game over territory uh magnus even goes
g6
it's another indication that the
position is so much feeling that you
don't even need a move like look at one
check
and i i thought rook f1 check was very
clean
the king had to move to the e file and
then after g6 you're going to go
king g5 g7 and rook f8 he's basically
done it
it's it's game over what a start for the
world champion
yeah absolutely i mean it was such a
nice position and
the show illustration of strength that
luka f1 check could have
could be played in uh one move later
so yeah it's and the english has
designed it's
it's one zero for magnus today wow
frightening
because again if you just go to the
opening
after knight takes e4 and knight f6 i
mean
it was like from that moment onwards
peter
i mean did magnus make
any mistake i mean it's like right here
right i mean this is
all preparation by ding lara and magnus
said
ha ha ha i've either seen this at home
myself
i'm going to play knight c5 and i know
my position
is great compensation and magnus played
flawlessly i mean i i i'm sorry again
i'm a fanboy but this
this was really impressive uh peter yeah
absolutely it was impressive
but also from my side i know that
sometimes there are surprises
and there are pleasant surprises this
one probably was a pleasant surprise and
we have tanja with us
tanya please thank you peter and you and
yas are absolutely right that despite
this being such an
offbeat opening especially the move c3
that he went for
in that position uh instead of knight d7
which has been played a couple of times
uh magnus his play was flawless
i was following it and i was seeing the
action and all the lines that you guys
were predicting and the way magnus was
playing i was checking it with the
computer
just every time the top move by the
computer just
absolutely insane how good this guy is
of course dingling had to take his
chances in the opening and try and get a
position which was uneven
and we all know i think we've heard it
from magnus himself
this is a this is a popular sort of a
notion that we have that
to to strike at the world champion or to
have any chances you've got to create a
mess on the board you know if you if you
go into strategical positions if you go
into positional battles
you don't have a great shot at that
dinglaryn
from the very start setting the tone
that he knows what he has to do but i
think it was extremely rash because at
the end of it
if you play a position that has
absolutely no sound
positional strength to the tactics that
are following or the mess that's on the
board
i think magnus is extremely strong in
these in these situations as well
because he knows
how to handle those complications and
we saw that in this game i mean just
flawless play going into from
a messy super messy opening i was
talking with the chess 24
chat and all of us were like what is
this opening this is going over our
heads and you know just no understanding
of what's happening
and then it just he converts it with
keeping the slight
edge throughout the game he converts it
into a very favorable rook pawn ending
and then just goes on to show
how superior his technique is which is
again a great time to remind everybody
that if you're having struggles with
endgame technique which is pretty much
all of us here right here
um definitely check out the 20 minute
free lesson by magnus carlsen on endgame
play
and perhaps perhaps we're never going to
be magnus carlsen but we can definitely
learn from the best and try
and um try and apply all his
his learnings and his experience in our
own place so check out that course go to
chastiable.com
and it's a free lesson it's a teaser for
what's to come tomorrow the big endgame
course the magnus touch
like i said we can't be magnus but we
could have the magnus touch in our games
so check that out and um we
also i'm gonna let peter and yas get a
quick coffee break while we talk about
what came up on twitter before game two
starts a quick reminder
thing lyran in a must-win situation
playing catch-up not only in their sets
but also
in the match today things could not have
gone better for the world champion today
starting with 1-0 with the white pieces
really
giving no chance to black whatsoever
ding tried to create a mess out of the
opening but just ended up
being paying for the mess himself let's
see what happens in game two but
of course uh yes things are not looking
good for ding to put it politely
let's move on and see what you guys have
to say on twitter we heard from
bippin and
bippin says can
can anyone explain how the candidates
for the various events were chosen
confused on what bases were those chosen
why no fabi or lev vivin that's actually
a great question
and this is uh i think uh um
i think this entire tour has featured
some of the best players in the world
and the selection process for this was
pretty clear
so the first event which was the magnus
carlsen invitational
the players were picked mostly the 10
players that played that were picked
mostly based on their world rankings on
their rapid rankings on being the
strongest in the world
and a certain feruja was picked because
he's ferugia
special the special talent i mean he had
to be there
so apart from that all the players were
based on just being the best in the
world
uh and of course availability was taken
into account now after the magnus
carlsen invitational and picking these
based
mostly on ranking and
the next event and the events that
followed they were chosen the top four
finisher of the previous event directly
qualified for the next event
so the top four semi-finalists of the
invitational went on to play the
linderous abbey
the top four in the linderis went on to
play the chessable masters
but also the six other players in the
magnus carlsen invitational each of them
was also given
a wild card into one of the other events
so
we had fabi who was given who played in
the invitational he did not make it to
the semis but was given a wild card for
the chessable masters
lev on our onion but in both these
events the first and the
and the chessable masters fabiano
caruana failed to come in the semi so he
did not advance in the tournament ahead
levon also played the second event again
but did not reach the top four
so that was a selection process the the
whole the whole tour started by just
picking players who are the best in the
world
and it continued by uh awarding the top
four finishers in the previous event
with a direct slot into the next event
and um yeah that's how it was done let's
move on to the next one
we had chess master riding in will ding
be able to repeat the sensation of the
first day let's play this
small clip that he sent us anything
doesn't need the win just trades the
bishops yeah i mean just absolutely
picture perfect by ding yeah flawless
follow this armageddon you can
you can see
you can see the frustration on the world
champion this was after day one after he
lost
that match he has not lost too many
matches in this entire tour of course he
was sensationally knocked out by hikaru
nakamura in the
linderous abbey rapids semi-final but
besides that it's been smooth sailing
and then here when the stakes were
really high magnus carlson started day
one with losing his first set and as
could be seen
he had um yeah he was not happy but what
a comeback by the world champion winning
two sets straight after that
wrapping up eat set in three games today
starts with a win
wilding be able to repeat the sensation
of the first day
i want to say no let's move on to the
yas is smiling yes
what's your take well
i mean just a second time outside i mean
it's tough everybody i mean come on i
mean this is just not fair
if the guy plays a flawless game how
you're supposed to win
tanya you made a you made a point that
you were actually
following the game with the chess engine
with the chest 24 chat
and you guys were kind of all struck by
magnus's play so i just got to
ask you where was
the mistake that ding made like where
did the computer go
oops that was a fault because it wasn't
like it was obvious to peter or i
that the position had deteriorated and
was suddenly lost
i mean it was like bang i mean so where
did the computer go
error i think yes it's just one of those
openings that you play to take your
opponent by surprise but it is a very
in general the foundations of the
opening that ding chose are extremely
dubious and
magnus just handled it really well the
engines never stopped giving
a slightly better position to magnus
especially after black ghost c3
with the trade-off and queen b3 um and
he just never lost control the point is
that magnus just did not make a mistake
despite being thrown off in the opening
and uh he kept going at it and at
some point just converted into a very
very favorable
end game very difficult to point out the
exact moment when things went completely
wrong
but it was around the time when white
played g4
that the advantage shifted in a big way
also after g5 and this entire bishop e6
things looked great for white and he
just went on to convert it
in style the computers say that black
perhaps in this ending could have
survived
but it was around the moment that white
went that black played h4 and gave up
this
next pawn in the rook pawn ending that
there was no coming back from it
here there are some suggestions like
rook d5 against the idea of rookie five
check
which sort of can keep black in the game
for a little longer
but still white's doing great and i
think it was just a question of
handling the opening really well and
slowly just building up on that
and after h4 there was no looking back
for black that's a dead lost
ending so that was the big mistake that
he made
let's get that last tweet up that we had
and we had baku's writing in with thank
you for the commentary and to yasser and
peter as well
yes there's a question for you are there
any plans on creating courses
uncheckable maybe for the french defense
i do know a certain anish giri who's
making a course on the french
so yes what about you absolutely
no question about it in fact for the
last couple of months i've been
uh taking a train up north from my home
here in hilversum holland to leewarden
where i've been
at the chesapeal studios digital
digitalizing uh these series of books
behind me i did this uh
winning uh chess uh
series of books what happened i don't
know if you guys had the
experience when you were at school my
i i'm in class and a kid comes in and
says the principal wants to talk to you
and i'm like oh no
you know i've been busted what did i do
i feel the statute of limitations runs
out after 24 hours as
as a kid if i don't get busted right
away i'm good
so i go to the principal's office and he
says
it's my understanding yes sir that
you're really good at chats
i go no i'm really not i'm not that good
yeah
you are i want you to teach chess in
school
as a curriculum i went what
i'm going to be the teacher he goes yeah
i said i get to give
my classmates a score a grade it goes
yeah
he says i said i you know i'm going to
give them an a
they go if they're good students they
deserve an a
i go and i can give myself a sc a score
he goes yeah
i said i'm going to give myself an a he
says you'll probably deserve it
i said this is great done deal so i
became a chess teacher
as a student while a student myself in
junior high
and as i started teaching the class i
started with seven kids
and we ended up with 42 okay they all
got a by the way
and i really really regretted that i
didn't have a curriculum
that i could just teach from in those
days it just
wasn't there so i literally i started my
own chess course and
later in the 90s microsoft came to me
microsoft press at the time
and said could you do a chess
educational series for us and i go
i go yeah i got it they go okay
and so those books
uh became a winning chess
series and now today everything is
digitalization right
and chessable with its move trainer you
know it's pattern recognition
move trainer as well as
all of the i want to say ais that go
with the chessable courses
you know marrying the content to the ai
of today is just fabulous and i've
started with
winning chess strategies and then it's
going to be
winning chess tactics and winning chess
combinations
and i think those three first books of
the series
uh we're gonna hold our breath and see
if they're well received by the public
and if they are
we're gonna do a lot more yes i have
i have no idea that anything that you
put out there is going to be amazingly
received you are
not only a common theatre extraordinaire
but also a trainer and
uh and your courses and just the way you
explain is absolutely magnificent it's
going to be gobbled up
so we can't wait for your series um also
we
heard from the chat a little complaining
going on from the chess
24 chat we had calvin amari writing in
moronic tweets get twenty percent of the
time and premium member chats get
zero percent of the time calvina murray
i hear you
here you are you are i am uh i am on the
chat i'm keeping an eye out we
definitely want to make the chat a part
of the show
i'm gonna try and do a better job at
that but see we get some of the chats on
the show as well
and now before we have liftoff of the
next game let's take a quick commercial
break we'd be right back
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back we do have liftoff of game
two dangler and playing catch up after
game one
let's hand it over to yas and peter to
take us through the action
thank you tanya and we do indeed have
liftoff game two uh ding loren
uh peter has decided to give e2 e4 a
rest
and he's gone back to his let's say
tried and true style of d4s and c4 made
him the number three player in the world
do you approve peter yeah i approve
completely i just feel like it's pity
that when he's not returning
to his mean weapon he is already
trailing today yeah it's
it adds to the pressure and magnus
surprisingly took some time something
like 30 seconds for his second move and
finally opted for g6
and we are seeing now the g3 grim fed or
the gc kings indian depending on
which setup magnus will choose it's
already not the first time
if we will get the g3 kings indian in
their match because from the rating move
order
yesterday we already had had that
interesting how it will develop
exactly and that was the that was a line
that kind
of went like knight c3 d6 knight f3 c6
and then you were uh explaining why to
your student
you had recommended the move e2 e4
yeah it seems like you are very very
prepared now yeah
well no i've just been i've been a bit
i've been soaking up all your knowledge
peter i feel like
i i wanna i wanna play
yeah but magnus is not giving ding a
chance to
to to come up with c6 e4 and magnus goes
knight c6 just as he did
i know not just as he did against me
because against me it was c5
castles knight c6 that
that was the line actually he used to
play he had couple of games with it
earlier on
but i don't recall him playing knight c6
short castles e5 i remember that he
played it from the right side he won
against feduza in saint petersburg uh
blitz world championship in uh
i mean it was a stunning game because
fuser had a fantastic event
you know i mean he was fighting against
all the very best players and then
finally he gets the chance on board one
to face malnourished carson
and i was there as a co-commentator with
miro uh you have nichenko and we were
kind of discussing yeah it will be very
interesting to see how magnus will
deal with uh alive because the very
young promising talent and so on it will
be probably a very sharp game
and magnus just demolished firoza in a
beautiful strategical manner i mean
fidos are never got into the game and
their magnus had the white pieces
and now suddenly he's on the black side
exactly and it's it's very very
surprising to me because dingleran
has a justified reputation as a fearsome
king's indian defense player
himself so oftentimes when you when you
playing against a person who
like you know who who's a great expert
in the grunfeld for example
it's not a very good idea to play the
grunfeld against a grunfeld expert
because
that player knows exactly where the
grunfell can get targeted
and here he is he's playing a king's
indian against a king's indian
defense player i mean it's it's like
is magnus purposefully challenging
himself
he wants to play the world's best and
he's not afraid to play
in their sand lot as well
yeah to be honest i'm completely
surprised
shocked i even don't know how to put it
i mean i would have never ever imagined
magnus choosing this exact setup but to
be fair
i mean this knight c6 e5 is a relatively
modern approach because
it became really popular once people
discovered that
d5 is actually answered very nicely by
knight b8 followed by a5 and black had
very very nice results with it
and for this fact the move dxe5 became
the main move in this position
and this is exactly how magnus reacted
against fioruza
so it's somewhat surprising that ding
went d5
and magnus bleeds out 97 because
it's uh i don't really believe that
there is any real modern terror in
i don't recall any real games uh played
in this exact variation
and after 97 the move e2 e4 a nice
move reinforcing the center and kind of
controlling the knight on e7 it can't
jump to f5 for whatever reasons
and then comes from white's point of
view the very natural
idea of expanding on the queen side
in principle uh you're as white you want
to play moves like knight e1 knight d3
b4 c5
or simply b4 c5 and in any case you're
trying to get in that break
and black that which explains why magnus
has played the move
a7 a5 because he's trying to slow down
why peter yeah absolutely and we should
point out that yeah it would be
simply strategically premature for white
to go b4 immediately because
exactly that's what black is waiting for
to strike it with
a5 and due to the fact that white is not
able to play a3
because of the pin along the a file this
exactly explain why
why takes prophylactic measures plays
first rook b1
now white does want to go b4 so magnus
doesn't give him the chance
he goes a5 and now white plays the
somewhat surprising move
rookie one but i think there is an
explanation because
he he needs to protect this e4 pawn
because oops i'm not not that
experienced with the
video arrows and i wanted to highlight
the e4 pawn that yeah this phone needs
some
extra protection there was nothing on
this diagonal
uh and and rookie one because just as
you
said the old classical way of thinking
about this position would be that this
knight on f3 is somewhat misplaced
let's bring it to to d3 where it belongs
yeah
right but uh probably
i mean simply again it's it's my respect
towards the players and
i'm pretty sure that they are big
experts in in this position
bing must have known that knights it's
probably better to to play rookie one
than
than knight e1 and i don't disagree in
terms of respect for the players but
i have an audience we have an audience
and they want to know
why white didn't play a3 and b4 peter
yes that that would be the very natural
question
but exactly here i think we we get an
answer
for it why why played the move rookie
one because after ac suddenly black has
this
very annoying move e5 a4 and you better
take this pawn but you can't because
your opponent e4 is is hanging and
if you are not taking now you try to
support the e4 pawn then black will just
simply protect his a4 pawn and you will
never ever manage to get
this before play and and then you are
strategically busted on the queen side
and that's the answer as to why mag
apart me why ding lyran
played rookie one he does want to play
b4 he really really really does
uh but he doesn't want to allow this a4
trick that that peter just pointed out
very nice thank you for that peter and
we have
after rookie one knight to d7
okay this is a very common
theme in the king's indian is black
black
needs activity he's getting suffocated
by the space
of the pawn on d5 he wants to break out
with f7f5 peter
yes but exactly for this reason also we
see that the knight on f3 actually is
is stupid at the moment but at the exact
minute black goes f5 white suddenly will
have the opportunity to
jump in the knight to g5 and head
towards the weekend e6 square
so this is probably one of the other
deep i mean that's the deeper idea
because
just protecting the e4 pawn and
preparing hd was kind of
easy to understand but this is another
aspect
and you know i was wondering that after
magnus had won this first game today
that
what has to happen in order that bing
has a chance to
to get back and you know i cannot
imagine any other scenario
for for ding than exactly this position
because it suits his style
he knows all the ideas uh it's not move
bad move he can just play some
really nice strategic game according to
his style and
magnus is also not such an expert in
this position so in in this regard
i really don't understand why magnus
voluntarily
chose to to enter this validation and
just your explanation peter forcibly
reminded me
of what you said yesterday in one of
those sicilian games the night or
sicilian where bishop takes a3 and
magnus
crashed through uh brilliantly on the
queen side
and it was sort of like the move knight
b3
did not come naturally to dingler in
because he spent
more of his life learning the catalan
and the king's indian and his instincts
are there
so right here now he's in a game
where he as you just very well put it he
knows the ideas he knows the themes he
knows even
the tactics as well as the end games
that come from this
so he really is playing in his territory
if i can use that term yeah absolutely i
mean
he has the bishop on g2 one can argue
that okay what do you do with this
bishop i mean this bishop is locked
yes it's perfectly true but all the
ideas still
remain kind of the same and also it's
not the typical
kings indian position from the black
side because uh
white is very stable all this it's not
like
black gets all the chances all the
freedom on the king's side to attack
and white has everything going on on the
on the queen side and who
who will be first with his uh with his
attack
i mean this is much more strategic and i
believe that
somehow this this should be
i mean should be exactly the scenario
that thing is
thing is looking forward to but i mean
i'm pretty sure that magnus has his own
agenda i mean
mangus wants to get into the finals and
by no means
he's trying to make his
pet as the